hey everyone today we are thrilled to
have a conversation about really the the
next step in our species urge to step
off of this planet and explore the
cosmos which of course is the Artemis
mission that we're going to have a
conversation about but all of this is
under the heading as many of you know
the Big Ideas programs of the world
Science Festival and there's really no
bigger idea than exploring the cosmos of
course you all know me
as a theoretical physicist who explores
some pretty big Ideas gravity quantum
mechanics unified theory and so forth
but just to get us going I might note
that when I was a little kid
I really wasn't thinking back then about
being a theoretical physicist I had two
goals for potential careers when I was I
don't know six seven or eight
one of them was to be a professional
bowler
uh you know you need to have good hands
for that and clearly clearly I don't the
other goal was to be you know like many
kids wanted to be an astronaut but for
me personally as I began to quickly
realize that I have intense
claustrophobia
that I get seasick even in the most
gentle boats even even on a swing I get
seasick so clearly I needed to remove
that thought and go back to the library
and just play with equations and that's
of course what I have done ever since
but our our conversation today is with
folks who have been utterly essential
to this remarkable Next Step where we
are going to go to the moon and Beyond
and that will be the conversation today
so let me bring in our first guest who
is Thomas Durgan
who is NASA's head scientist he's the
associate administrator for the science
Mission directorate and that directorate
has as its mission to understand the
origins Evolution and Destiny of the
universe and he joins us from his home
just outside of Washington welcome
Thomas thanks for joining us glad to be
here thanks so much excellent and our
second guess is David Newman who's
NASA's former Deputy Administrator she
is currently the Apollo program
professor of astronautics at MIT where
she runs the MIT media lab and she is
joining us from her office in Cambridge
Massachusetts welcome Deva thank you so
much great to see you both welcome your
voice I don't quite see you yet I don't
know if that's trying to illustrate like
a black hole or something of that sort
but uh but but Thomas do you see Deva or
is it just a glitch on my end uh not yet
I just remember when we did the test we
had the same thing all of a sudden she
popped up so I hope okay I'm gonna I'm
assuming that David will pop up but if
nothing else it'll be like the voice of
God David so you will be uh with us
certainly in audio form but we hope in
visual as well so let's just Jump Right
In
Thomas you know the artist Miss Mission
um it almost launched a couple of times
um there was great anticipation in fact
I was over at CNN the morning of one of
the launches and I learned like 10
seconds before we went live that that
had been scrubbed
it was this unexpected or I mean
obviously you don't want it to happen
but is it surprising with some thing
this complicated that there would be
these glitches and route to the
successful launch
look at the short and the longest it's
not surprising right it's a very complex
Mission a really complex launch vehicle
that on top of it has a complex Orbiter
uh the Orion internationally build that
Orbiter and now what happens as you get
then steps through uh the whole launch
proceedings uh there are things you're
learning and frankly in this case it had
a lot to do about both the ground system
but also on the rocket of the entire
plumbing and kind of the the overall
decision making related to liquid
hydrogen especially it's a well-known
problem that uh frankly uh even during
the shuttle era created a number of
issues and uh I was just like you I went
to everyone of those launch attempts and
finally on the third one of course I saw
it lift off the pad and just absolutely
remarkable yeah it must that must be an
incredibly
exciting moment with a with a successful
watch so congratulations on that Dave
are you uh I think you are with us at
least in spirit I can see you I can hear
you I can see you I'm I'm here okay
fantastic okay so we have a a very
studious looking still image of you
which is going to drive my questions to
be a little bit more serious than they
otherwise would be which is fine but
Debbie you're now at MIT but for a
period of time you were right up there
at the top of NASA so what does the
success of this launch mean to you
personally oh it's uh it's huge as the
Apollo program professor at MIT it's
been 50 years but we're back and uh it's
a completely new era of space
exploration uh much more democratized
frequency but I it's been it's been hard
work and you know congrats to the entire
NASA Team all the contractors that this
really took it took a nation and it
can't be understood dated and it's hard
it's hard work I went to the first two
launch of towns I couldn't make it for
the third but the great thing is the
third time was a charm and it shook all
of Florida I mean that's how impressive
this is heavy lift launch is something
truly special and uh I say now we're
back and so much so much science and
exploring to do yeah which is great
because Florida does need a good shaking
but that's for a different a different
conversation but um you mentioned the
Apollo Mission and and that is a name in
your professorship at MIT and look I
don't know how many of our viewers are
old enough like me to have remembered
the the Apollo Mission certainly some
are but those who aren't no doubt have
seen films about that remarkable period
so can you give us a sense of the
comparison between say the Apollo
Mission and and what Artemis is doing
and seeks to achieve
is that for me Brian yes it is excellent
so I love the the video that's showing
now and so uh again uh Saturn V and the
Apollo program that's the largest uh
launch vehicle heaviest launch vehicle
we've ever had and now here's Artemis uh
surpassing it so uh it's just really
phenomenal in terms of this much rocket
power what we can launch this is of
course Artemis one it'll be followed by
Artemis 2 which will have the crew on
board so this is the dress rehearsal uh
for the crew on board and then Artemis 3
will be landing on the moon so that's
the the sequence uh just just hard to
describe an amount of uh heavy lift
launch capability that we they have on
this rocket uh you know it takes three
days to get to the Moon is it's far away
and uh so it's really uh heavy lift is
uh it's the way we explore deep space to
the to the moon but also onward to Mars
and that's why we need this capability
and uh we're back
yeah so I'd love to talk about Mars in
just a moment but just sticking with the
moon for the time being
you know there certainly will be some
who hear about us going back to the moon
and I don't know not be as excited as
perhaps we were back in the 60s we've
been there some would say we've already
done it what is the motivation say
Thomas for for going back to the moon at
the moment
so look uh there's a number of reasons
we go to the moon but I think for me as
the science lead at Nasa the most
exciting one is we're going to a moon
that's really different than the one we
left in terms of our understanding of
the celestial body and understanding
that has truly evolved the questions
that are currently at the heart of
science the highest priority questions
as prioritized for us not by some
internal NASA committee but by the
national academies in the United States
kind of include questions of the Moon
that are relate very much to water uh uh
kind of one of the big surprises being
that this kind of body without any
atmosphere really has water at its polar
regions but also embedded in in some of
the The Reckless kind of as found on the
ground a huge surprise uh from uh you
know the time from our our understanding
of the Moon there the second one really
is our understanding of the actual
timing of the planetary system kind of
evolution kind of our solar system that
of course went through massive changes
including changes where outer planets
like Neptune started moving out kind of
in a kind of a moment of instability
that created chicken of showers of of
rocks through the entire inner solar
system which of course left scars on the
Moon and what the academies tell us go
back and actually take that uh very much
by picking up samples and do so kind of
by creating a collection of samples that
Rivals the scientific impact that the
Apollo samples have had those are two of
several science topics that really have
changed our understanding and interest
in our Celestial uh you know neighbor
here our moon
yeah I remember I don't know maybe it
was 10 or 15 years ago it could be
longer if there was a professor who
tragically died not long ago Arlene
Kratz whose office was right upstairs
and he would we go on walks along
Riverside Park sometimes and he'd tell
me about this idea that there was water
on the moon so it's so exciting to have
a sense that now it's really going to be
explored do we currently have a sense of
of how much
water is there
so it's a it's an interesting question
right what we have is we have at least
three observations from from space one
of them by the way from the earth using
an infrared telescope in the upper
atmosphere but the others in orbit
around kind of looking at those shaded
creators uh you know uh using different
types of radiation infrared but also uh
radio and then other type of
observations what we really need to do
though to really turn that into actual
quantities and what we need to do is
actually go land and pick up some of
these samples and actually look at it
kind of we need a calibration tie point
to really if you want knock down the
error bars but just the range of water
is is in in every way related to uh
amounts that would fundamentally change
how we explore and of course David has
done a lot of work in this and so David
what do you see is the I mean obviously
water on the moon is exciting water on
any
extraterrestrial body suggests the
possibility you know out there of life
that's certainly the motivation for
exoplanets what's the motivation here is
it is it to to set a base and we can
mine for water or or what what will the
utility of water on the moon give us in
these Explorations so it helps us answer
uh that big question you know what about
life what about life out there now I'm
talking about becoming interplanetary so
for me as a technologist I look at the
Moon and say this is our chance this is
our chance to demonstrate the
Technologies and buy those down we'll
get to Mars to really answer that
question did life exist but the first
and foremost Thomas mentioned let we get
to the South Pole
um that's where we're going to go to
take a look
um at the eyes we need to measure it
monitor it where we have some MIT
experiments going to like little robotic
ant swarms if you will on the commercial
opportunities and then uh depth field
camera as well we don't have that
information to to you know have this
technology for future human missions
there's just so much that we need to
study so I look at the whole lunar
surface as a test bit to enable our
future
um human missions and so back down to
the South Pole you see what was the
quantity of the The Ice there
um we really have to learn in-situ
resource utilization how do you live off
the land no matter where you go into
deep space so this these are all the
technologies that we really need to to
demonstrate Mobility first with well
Lander first Mobility with Rovers and
then our scientific instruments that
prepare us for the human missions when
it's the human missions then of course
we need to worry about keeping people
alive and they're pressurized Rovers in
a mobile spacesuits the whole life
support system so these are all the
Technologies now that we have heavy lift
launch that was number one heavy this
lunch now we get out there into deep
space and we start testing these
different Technologies is to enable the
next decade and decades coming for both
robotic and human flights it's really
it's not one versus the other form of
robotic sensors assistance that we
envision is exactly what what NASA is
teeing up with International Partners as
well to really explore the moon uh in
you know in the this coming decade is
super exciting and everyone can
participate students faculty or
International colleagues it's really
wonderful it really has been
democratized the secondary payloads on
Artemis those are mostly from schools
and they're just small payloads high
risk they're more than 50 percent of
them are working and that just gives
everyone an opportunity to see
themselves as participating in space
exploration so I'd like to explore both
those points a little bit further first
you you mentioned Robotics and there's
certainly a perspective among some
scientists I'm sure some members of the
general public that maybe the smarter
thing to do would be to just use robots
so we don't have to worry about all the
the dangers in technology that's
developed to preserve life in
environments that are so hostile to at
least Life as we know it why not just do
robots why have people involved in this
so uh if you don't mind that data if you
don't mind you know you could make the
same argument about the Antarctic and
Volcanic activities on earth right kind
of their hazardous areas where you could
go with robots and you could explore and
what the top scientists do whether it's
at MIT and every other university around
what they do is they go there in person
they also bring robots but the right way
to explore volcanoes even though it's
dangerous is to bring somebody with
judgment somebody with tremendous
insights kind of reading the environment
and understanding their signs and
somebody who of course then is
supplemented complemented with uh robots
to get uh kind of an exploration program
going so why would the moon why would
Mars be different Deva yeah so I love
that and so we've been exploring Mars
for 50 years with our orbiters and then
our Landers and our Rovers and that's
amazing and uh so all that data we have
back but I submit the first human
mission that we send will surpass in
terms of Mobility with that the human
intellect the high value-added science
we're going to have our Rovers and
robots with us amazing what we're doing
right now with perseverance and jezero
crater all this is great data but you
add on uh the the human component
and our chances just really went up
significantly to find that evidence of
past life so it's a combination I it's
it's the exploration teams and we are
out in the field we're doing analog
studies and there's always people and
there's always our machines and Rovers
together so it's really very synergistic
just make sure the humans are doing the
high value added for humans make sure
your robots and your robotic systems are
doing the high value added the precursor
collect the data run 24 7 because then
the humans can make the decisions out
this is the best highest value
scientific in a waypoint that we need to
study so it really is a team working
together and um you know there's always
humans on the mission even if it's a
robotic Mission we're back here at
Mission Control you know putting input
into the system so I always say there's
always humans and and Automation and
robots involved in any space mission
makes sense absolutely so Thomas if you
can just give us a sense of where are we
right now with with Artemis so it
launched I guess a couple nights ago I
admit that I was otherwise preoccupied
so I didn't actually get to to watch
this one where where is the Orion
capsule now and what's its what's the
plan from here toward Splashdown which I
guess is sometime in uh early December
is that correct yeah so so basically uh
it launched and uh just the one thing I
want to tell you Brian and I know you
appreciate that is that the models that
we had of uh the propulsion you know the
8.8 million pounds of thrust and the
entire orbit within 0.3 percent uh of
what the performance was what was close
to the predictions absolutely right down
the middle uh yesterday morning it did
the burn and went into orbit around the
moon so yesterday evening looking into
the sky for the first time you know if I
my entire lifetime is a human capable uh
you know system in orbit uh out there
that I'm looking at and I'm just so
excited uh Friday is the second burn
that we're gonna do uh and you know
right now there's kind of uh high
resolution imagery showing up you see it
uh around and social media we're going
to uh release them like we always do on
the 5th of December we're going to leave
uh the moon and kind of come down on the
11th uh of December and uh and complete
that test flight remember there's a lot
of Mission to be done ahead of us
because of the fact that one of the key
risk items of course that entire entry
descent and uh and kind of that thermal
uh protection part of the system which
is which is so critical for human
survival of course when we come back so
that's the heat shield again exactly the
heat shield urine the heat shield and
and uh and really the whole the
parachutes all the relevant systems that
actually protect uh the lives human
lives as we go down so the next flight
will be the one with astronauts four
astronauts sitting on top of it uh for a
kind of an Apollo eight like of kind of
uh circum lunar flight so so we're
really in the middle of it things are
going well we are of course encountering
some issues that's what you would expect
you know the same is true even with the
James Webb's face telescope uh you know
everything went really really well we
worked issues and the team is doing
really well uh uh with uh Artemis right
now kind of the issue starting down with
the international team with Orion really
working together hand in hand just a
wonderful moment in time right now
this is an uncrewed Mission but I gather
that there's kind of a a crew right
there are mannequins I've heard that you
have renamed moonachins if I
heard that nomenclature correctly so can
you just give us a sense of of who's on
board
David why don't you take it if you will
okay there's a absolutely well so that's
that's a mannequin you see there as uh
you know in the the crew seat that's
really important again instrumented
taking all the data we want to know the
whole profile of the mission for the you
know next uh Mission which has the
humans on work and uh Snoopy's there as
well uh so I don't know if everyone's
seen the little little orange Snoopy
which is scientific because when
Snoopy's floating around can definitely
give us a show us the weightless
environment for the microgravity
environment you always want to take
Snoopy on all your space missions
actually when the crew go they wear
their Snoopy cap inside of the spacesuit
when when when they go out so it really
is a complete dress rehearsal for the
next mission for when the humans are
born so everything is as realistic and
as similar as as possible to make sure
that you want to do the dress rehearsal
then for Artemis 2 the upcoming flight
with the crew and what sort of dangers
or measurements are you making to be
aware of potential dangers when there's
life on board radiation measurements or
things of that sort what are you
actually doing so radiation is deep
space so again we've been in low earth
orbit for the last 40 plus years so now
we go back to deep space so absolutely I
take radiation measurements the you know
uh what's about the vibration uh
especially on launch Thomas mentioned
when we come back in so you have to
categorize the entire loading the
vibration envelopes analysis uh you know
hopefully that's a few G's a few times
body weight loading and thermal thermal
is of the utmost importance you're
coming in screaming literally screaming
back to the Earth's atmosphere and the
Orion vehicle is magnificent it's
designed for that but you know
everything will be monitored and
thousands of sensors to really capture
that that thermal environment the stress
environment on the loads uh the
vibrations everything coming to make
sure we keep our astronauts very safe
and and Well on a pro coach and Landing
back to Earth and so Thomas what do you
think the time frame is going to be
between the measurements that are taken
on Artemis one and the next Artemis that
is meant to be crude is that a year two
years five years what do you think it's
going to take the plan right now is uh
just because of the supply chain issues
and everything is uh close to two years
so that's what we're we're already
working on it if you go visit uh
Mississippi walk in there you see the
rocket being built it's not uh right now
there's a lot of signs that you talk
about David that a lot of uh will be
analyzed of course it's the radiation
vest on these uh on these uh models that
you know German and Israeli build
radiation vests that are doing their
work uh really trying to see how we can
protect them and I think the one thing I
want to mention Ryan is that we already
created a record we will so do so again
by really bringing life from Earth into
deep space we're actually extended in uh
Dimension kind of in in this distance
from the earth kind of the time we've
ever brought Earthbound life and of
course we brought a fungi and we brought
a single cell organisms all of which are
basically doing uh active measurements
of really uh the radiation environment
and how the evolution in that
environment is is in fact progressing so
so a lot of this work very much in the
center of uh biological and physical
science type of uh communities that are
really interested in this again A lot
has happened since the Apollo program so
it's time to kind of bring all that
knowledge to Bear yeah I mean when you
think back to Apollo I mean just
comparing the computational capacity
back then and today I I I I gather there
are two redundant computers on Artemis
Each of which has its own two redundant
computers you've got multiple levels
with computing power that's thousands of
times it must be thousands of times
greater than what was on Apollo just
think about you know your cell phone
compared to what things were back in the
1960s so were those astronauts crazy
back in the 60s for getting into that
into in into the Apollo Mission with
that comparatively rudimentary capacity
that we had back then
well I think you know uh innovation
and uh at the most Innovative project
and crazy project it was really really
similar at the beginning right and I I
just really believe what uh multiapolo
program as a demonstration is how much
humans can achieve that truly work
together and bring the best out in each
other and in my way in my mind you know
having sat with the Artemis program and
especially recognizing how much more
diverse and much more uh International
the Artemis program is I have no doubt I
already see it now how even more kind of
we can achieve with with that uh kind of
uh uh team and and again there will be
moments where what we're trying to put
ahead of us you know landing on Mars you
know and and uh coming back from it will
sound crazy to many people that uh but
that is how Innovation looks in its
early stages just before you know what
is science fiction through science
becomes uh reality so so I really I I do
me Apollo has always been a huge
inspiration because of the value of
teams coming together doing the
impossible yeah you know David when you
look at
photographs of the astronauts in the
Apollo Mission if you sort of squint
your eyes it's the first approximation
they all kind of look the same
and there's there's a wonderful
commitment to change that going forward
so you can you give us a sense
um you know from the time that you were
at Nasa and from what you're aware of
going forward what that commitment is
and and what the future missions will
look like yeah most simply is space for
all and so when we go back and we go
back so that uh you know those gentlemen
all look alike and they were amazing
amazing test pilots again maybe a little
bit crazy but what Apollo first what
taught me taught me to dream you know as
a young girl watching it you taught us
to dream surely it's Thomas fish if we
can focus we could get humans to the
moon now the message is it's for
everyone look at this diversity of our
astronauts the first woman will step um
you know onto the lunar surface they'll
be International Crews of course we come
from it's it's a representation of the
world and the globe and every you know
young person out there listening to us
he she they they should they should see
themselves they should see themselves
represented because they're all
superstars right they we want them to
all take our jobs that's the that's the
The Hope and the inspiration is to make
sure that um all of our kids can see
themselves and they realize also just
how fortunate we are uh to be back at
the moon today I mean I'm actually a
little giddy I can't believe we're
having this conversation we are in orbit
around the Moon I've been waiting a long
time to say that we are in orbit around
the moon and that's for all Humanity you
mentioned the computations millions of
times more um capable and now we can
actually get that data even in real time
very close to real time you know we have
a short delay for the moon but that's
really important as well because a few
lucky astronauts will go on the next
mission in orbit then land but guess
what all of the data all of the science
all the technology that's for the world
so hope that everyone listens this this
is for you this is for all of us
together on you know this really
inspirational focus of to become
interplanetary yeah inspiration is
indeed the the right word it's it's
wonderful and remarkable and Debbie
you've also done uh groundbreaking work
in trying to make The Human Experience
in space more
um bearable because if it's going to be
open to a wider group of individuals
those clunky spacesuits that we're all
familiar with
they've got to have an upgrade and
you've been pioneered in that regard so
you can give us a sense of what you've
been doing there sure we've been working
on that it's a kind of a change to
design period and we need to kind of
take the human body and I design a
pressure a layer if you will from from
the person out I want to enable Mobility
have a very light system we learn a lot
from the current technology that's the
gas pressurized suits but they're the
current one on Space Station 140 kilo is
a very heavy suit for for the Artemis
suits going forward to be pressurized as
well we really look forward to
demonstrating some technology maybe
hybrid you know your arms and legs you
really want to move you want to move
move well we don't want to waste your
energy moving gas pressurized suit of
course you need the pressure layer that
what the pressure is doing you're in a
vacuum you're in the vacuum of space on
the moon is a vacuum so you need the
pressure there then you need the whole
life support system you know providing
your oxygen to breathe scrubbing out
your carbon dioxide dioxide so it's a
great engineering challenge but rather
than taking the spacecraft and shrinking
it around the person going to say let's
take the person or you know like the you
know Olympic Athlete we're in the World
Cup now it is you know let's take that
that amazing capability of the person
and design the life support systems
around them and and so what does it feel
like to be in in one of these uh
Christian Dior spaces
I wish I knew that was a sponsor that'd
be great
um so well you're over pressurized so
it's a third of an atmosphere so uh the
pressure production that we need for any
spacesuit guest pressurized or you know
strictly on the skin is a 30 kill
pascals or a third of an atmosphere so
when you're in the lab and doing the
research and development your one
atmosphere like we are having this chat
and we over pressurized to 1.3 it feels
tight it's okay you jump into a vacuum
chamber and now you're in a you know 30
30 kilopascals a third of an atmosphere
feels great you know if you're in in the
real test chamber
um for a vacuum test chamber so it'll
feel you know fine when we're there but
pressure is just part of it you really
need all your thermal control as well
you need all of your other life support
systems
um and again going to the Moon is really
cold or you know really hot we have you
know plus or minus 200 degree
temperature differentials so also the
thermal we paid a lot of attention to
how do you still be very mobile but we
have to think about the thermal
properties and we mentioned before
radiation for human emissions in the
future radiation in deep space is is the
number one Challenge and how you know
I'm focused on digits these days what
what greater facility does this give for
the fingers to be able to do more fine
work in space it's really important the
design of a glove if we can make it
tight fitting tight fitting to the hand
you have more degrees of freedom here in
my in my hand my fingers Hunters because
then my whole body combined
so the glove design and that was
actually the number one complaint from
the Apollo Astronauts I mean they were
great they had the right stuff but they
really beat up their their hands they
would have loved to had more mobility in
their fingers to do to do more work and
more Mobility to you see the the two
foot Bunny Hop
um that was because the suit had limited
Mobility so they would really like to
have natural human performance as they
can because uh you know we're not going
there to sit around we're going there to
work so do science do work so we really
want to enable you know empower the
astronauts to have as much Mobility hand
dexterity as they possibly can so how
close are you from prototype to actually
implementation Thomas will will these be
the suits in in Artemis too
uh Ava are you working with any one of
the companies with these particular
suits we are we are the yep the um
because the folks who the the industry
folks who are working the suits were
great friends from Academia our our job
is to push them show them hey guys look
at this technology we want so again
maybe some hybrid again test betting
since we're going to the Moon let's try
out some of these Advanced Technologies
so we really want to infuse some of our
technologies will it be a complete
biosuit trunk rap person probably no
that's not under contract but we work
really closely with the the industry
folks and they have the appetite
especially folks going uh in the future
you know the private folks they have the
appetite to fly the best technology
possible so uh matter of fact you know
just last week we were all talking
industry and Academia and what we bring
you know is some technology and some
some different thinking
um and we work together well because at
the end of the day the industry folks
who do need to provide a flight
qualified system you know and that's
there's no there's no change for uh for
that so we need to work together so we
can flight qualify keep the astronauts
safe and well so it'll it'll be a team
effort I hope between the universities
and Industry as well as as well as NASA
of course and the other yeah and Brian
and I what what I'm really excited about
and this is the suits are really a good
example right what when the Apollo
program was started it was done so
largely not not exactly but it was done
so with a very strong government uh
Focus uh kind of uh with you know some
contractors very much in isolation kind
of really focused on that government
entity and that's one of the key
elements of the Artemis program that the
commercial and kind of academic partners
are such an important part of any one of
those activities as are the
international partner you know the
European service module right now
attached to Orion is actually propelling
it uh going forward and kind of I love
the suit the example that we're talking
about you know with Ava being a key
innovator on it but but exact that's
what we should be doing as uh the Apollo
has borne a lot of fruit it has created
an industry so let's call you know let's
actually partner with that industry
instead of going back to a paradigm that
was necessary at the beginning but it's
no longer the best Paradigm today so
given industry as a vital partner as
both of you have mentioned everybody
who's watching this is well aware of the
privatization of space travel from Blue
origin SpaceX and so forth so so so
Thomas can you give us a sense I mean do
you do you consider
this to be um a competitive between
government and Industry is a fully
symbiotic are you all working hand in
glove what's the relationship between
say you and and SpaceX and blue origin
so first and foremost uh you know we're
enormously proud at Nasa to have spawn
kind of a series of companies and
innovators that have taken in many cases
technology from NASA and have made it
cut off into products that we now can
buy so kind of practically how that
looks to us from the science Mission
director it is is that the cost to orbit
you know of a mission whether it's an
astrophysics Mission or one that looks
at our most beautiful home planet that
uh that launch capability actually has
has uh tremendously become cheaper so
even during my time at Nasa which Devon
and I overlapped for a few months there
but uh even during my time at first
since that just the last six plus years
the overall cost to launch has gone down
by more than 10 more than 15 percent
right and so for us that's just
enormously successful so frankly we
don't wanna uh build with very very few
exceptions options systems that we can
go buy out there if there's multiple
companies and that is good now I want to
just tell you Brian uh
there is a very human part to it that we
should not go kind of ignore and that is
that there's amazing people let's say a
chance and a rap more show that have
done a specific job and one morning
somebody says we don't need this anymore
and I just want to make sure that that
transition that kind of human kind of
transition is is kind of recognized as
such you know those people were
successful that's why we have those
options and sometimes you know when I
see in social media especially you know
people kind of don't quite recognize the
enormous achievement of those
individuals who of course are being
trained to do other amazing things we
want to be at the bleeding edge of
what's possible with NASA and there's a
lot of uh possibilities but that's how I
see it and would you say that there's um
a complimentary role in Zeitgeist of
space travel I mean some would say that
NASA as a government agency has to focus
more on human safety it has to focus
more on minimizing risk than say a
private company like SpaceX or blue
origin so maybe the Private Industry let
them do the more risky stuff try it all
out and then once it works maybe then
absorb the insights back into NASA is
that the kind of Rhythm that one
imagines going forward
so I think it's absolutely clear that
the best set of opportunities we create
within the country is by all of us being
best at what we do so for example the
James wife Space Telescope and I love
your necklace uh Deva you know I've seen
it there kind of that that is something
that no private company today would
entertain right it's very very very
complex there's so many new technologies
that's exactly what we should be doing
however after we've developed those
things you know there are companies that
are out there developing for example
Earth observing systems and yes they can
they can make them cheaper and they can
launch a fuel even if they break first
and you know like they don't have to go
to Congress to testify whether or not
that was worth the taxpayers money
because they're working with the
investors directly and what we can now
do we can buy those data and make them
available for a scientists to do it so
together we can do by us being best at
what we what we're bringing to the table
we can together do more than any one of
us together it really is a symbiotic
it's a complementary relationship that I
think has the most promise here and and
what will the next step then be with all
of the players contributing are we going
to colonize the Moon is that is that are
we going to have a permanent base there
what do you think is going to happen
Dave I see you shaking your head in the
in the negative Thomas I thought I saw
the affirmative so I'm just curious like
I'm just taking my head further we're
not going to colonize anything I hope I
mean I hope we've run that experiment
didn't didn't go so well so again we
need to to go as explorers and uh I just
object to the to again we really are
thinking about democratizing it to the
public-private Partnerships
is that just the wrong word that I use
you think or is it really fundamental I
mean I think it's fundamental I think
it's I think it's fundamental why would
we colonize why would that's a very uh
you know human-centric a very Western
eccentric way why wouldn't we go there
again how we're really going to get
exploration right let's go live off the
the land and so I think the change in uh
cultural attitudes that we're all in
this so we're all in this together for
all living things past and present I
just so it is the the terminology we're
going to go globally hopefully it's it's
again it won't be one nation state if we
can pool our resources together and our
great ideas will go representing
humanity and actually I think Apollo did
that for us too it was humans that went
to the moon sure NASA but people were so
proud that humans go to the moon so I
think if we follow in that vein that
humans will are now back uh you know
with our brains uh in orbit and our
spacecraft around the Moon well a land
but I think going going forward uh again
that with that humility that it is uh
for for everyone uh just so it's a
different different mindset and then
we're going to do it we need governments
absolutely governments and NASA is
funded so you're uh you need that
government support to your point and
governments should I think also they do
need to actually do take the risk look
Beyond so that's why moon and Mars
that's what NASA it has to be out there
on the Forefront taking those risks um
the companies are incredible and guess
what that they also have a bottom line
so if the business case closes that's
why it's going to be low earth orbit
what can you do that's it's um that the
companies can do to make more of a
business so it looks really good for low
worth orbit again for the moon and Mars
This is deep space exploration in my
opinion and we go there especially to
Mars find evidence of that past life
that was probably there the evidence is
is mounting but we do it together we
invite everyone and that says Thomas
said everyone has their own expertise
and so it's that teaming Arrangement how
we can have the private folks government
folks and the academic folks how we can
all work together best
I'm just wondering is there a real
version of unobtainium
yeah the the uh the imaginary element on
avatar the Avatar series is that is that
something I mean there are industry
folks thinking in that direction that
they're going to exploit the resources
hopefully in a positive way but as that
was driving some of the public-private
partnership in this
there's some ideas about that um that's
that's not uh you know I think that the
the inspiration to me again is it get
get it right go beyond become
interplanetary let people dream find it
scientifically find the evidence of life
elsewhere we're working on the evidence
this mountain we're going to find it
that's why we need our our ocean worlds
missions as well where are we going to
find life you know just in the the solar
system the exoplanet so again given both
of your backgrounds in space science you
know it's just amazing it's amazing how
much that we don't know back to James
Webb just really investigating finding
out uh you know Dark Matter dark energy
that's breakthrough that's scientific
it's a revolutionary uh you know
breakthrough science and so when you
look at it across the world there's
there's roles for you know the
government and for individuals private
entities and so I kind of think that
just to kind of depends on how far away
from from Earth you go I think the the
world uh you know governments are are
gonna oh need to to prop up the
exploration you know the far scientific
exploration and so Thomas what do you
think about the The Next Step I know
part of the Artemis Mission I don't know
which number it would be
um three or four maybe four you tell me
that's meant to head out to Mars so is
that on a time table that you can
actually give us a sense of now or is
that too much in the future to speculate
uh so let me look before I answer that
question let me just quickly give you
where the the body language disconnected
was between Deva and I it was not about
the point that she made I actually fully
agree with her and one thing I wanted to
say that it's certainly our goal to
create kind of a presence uh the surface
of the Moon kind of that is really
taking allowing us to take advantage but
creating vehicles for example that both
can be uh you know crude but also can be
autonomous and then kind of do for
example collect uh collect samples of
the type that really answered always
fundamental kind of science questions
that relate to uh to our uh to our
history you know in the history of the
solar system also uh kind of opening up
exploration areas that look at the
universe in ways that frankly we cannot
from Earth like the Dark Ages you know
uh where basically any Observatory on
Earth or in space near the Earth is
overwhelmed by the radio noise of both
the Sun the Earth or uh giant planets
the moon can create things like that
well so look we are at Marsh already
with robots and uh we've been there for
a while uh and uh with the human
exploration part of it uh we have
basically uh said it will really uh
sincerely we're already now of course
looking at Technologies for that but but
uh the human missions were really big
enough in the late 30s and uh uh kind of
where we're really focused towards that
objective and and there's a lot of work
that remains to be done you know kind of
any kind of mission at the Moon as
actually creating tool sets that we will
use going forward including of course
the great Gateway which is really kind
of a Space Capsule in which uh we'll
learn how to uh kind of survive for a
long time in in deep space with humans
which is very much analogous to kind of
a Transit time which is multi-month kind
of away from it uh you have seen just
recently uh Brian the uh the technology
demonstration media just two weeks ago
on top of a launch of a weather
satellite where we inflated a heat
shield on the way down and kind of
demonstrated that this large the six
meter heat shield in this case could
survive kind of entry on Earth it needs
to be three times that amount but that
took would take care of one of the core
technology worries that we have at this
moment in time for humans so we're
already very impatiently pushing uh
towards that but my guess is it's uh
it's not Artemis 4 it's uh beyond that
we we're going to do multiple ordinance
missions to the Moon before we uh get
going on on our Journey to Mars and so
you both anticipate and again I I take
the point David that the the connotation
of colonization is a is the wrong way of
of approaching it but I I imagine when
we think about Mars will NASA be
planning that as a one-way mission in
terms of the the folks that are going or
are you going to do it as they're going
to go and come back it's going to be so
into the moon I love the moon you know
I'm actually from MIT in our space
exploration as we call it to the Moon to
stay so just so that we're on the same
page again that's what we want to do we
want to be on the moon and learning and
and we call it be there to stay with
humans with robots you know back and
forth when uh so both uh Thomas and I
are kind of again shaking our heads here
because we know it's it's a round trip
it's with humans it's a round-trip
Mission to Mars and uh it's even going
to be a round trip we got to get these
samples we're taking amazing samples
today on the surface of Mars so the next
Mars mission is sample return we need to
get those sample goes back to Earth
we're going to learn so much from the
currently stowed samples that we're
taking right now with perseverance so
that's a round trip as well you know so
we got to get those samples back and
then envisioning the human missions our
round trip that's that's ethical it's um
think about uh we talked about
Antarctica before
Antarctic is not populated you know why
Antarctica is not populated people don't
want to live there it's really cold it's
isolated combined Mars
a hundred a thousand times worse you
know moon is three days away uh Mars
eight months so sure we want to go there
as explorers but guess what everyone's
gonna miss their family their friends
everyone you know and love is right here
on you know spaceship herb on planet
Earth so it's really thinking about it
in round trips and I love to think about
just having that space infrastructure
when you can take a space plane to the
moon or lunar orbit you can maybe go to
Mars so I look at it as you know humans
literally living off planet and having
those options uh in a transportation
system to go to the moon or or Mars
longer term and I gather part of the key
to that will be related to what we
discussed before you need to be able to
mine your own fuel as opposed to carry
your fuel so where do we stand on that
we're uh I think we're hitting out of
the park hopefully we have Moxie the MIT
uh experiment so it's in situ resource
utilization or isru we take that carbon
dioxide Mars atmosphere it's very thin
you know one percent seo2 but we take
that and then essentially from the CO2
um oxygen a CO2 environment of Mars we
split off the the carbon atoms and then
we recombine the the carbon to C2 and
you're left with um steel carbon dioxide
so it's kind of like a reverse um
um kind of fuel exchanger if you will
take in the carbon dioxide uh split the
carbon and the oxygen recombine and then
we're left with uh oxygen now so why are
we making oxygen and O2 on Mars simply
so it's a technology demonstration an
unbelievable technology demonstration we
can make it like six grams per hour so
it's not enough to keep you alive and
you mentioned the first and foremost the
primary use is to demonstrate for fuel
if you have your oxygen supplies if we
can create oxygen out of the Martian
atmosphere then you know you have your
full fuel tank for a round trip so it
completely changes the architecture of a
human Mars trip if you can make your
fuel if we have fuel Depots if you will
for that first second all the missions
do you have enough oxygen uh and can you
think about that on the return trip
secondarily it might be for the
spacesuit keep people alive but first
and foremost it would be for fuel for
propulsion for that return vehicle back
from from Mars to Earth
just having a someone more speculative
direction as we uh reach toward the end
of our time
Debbie you noted that in some sense the
old spacesuits were as if we took the
space vehicle and shrunk it around the
person so that the pressurization that
they experienced in the ship would now
be mobile and they could walk in their
own mobile version of the rocket ship
that of course is trying to create an
environment that fits human Life as We
Know It
can can you imagine a time when we might
change the genome or change the makeup
volitionally a kind of volitional
intelligent design if you will which is
the language used by a friend of mine
Martin Reese so that we would have
individuals that would be tailor-made
their physiology would be tailor-made
for the harsh environment so for them it
wouldn't be harsh and then that way sort
of change the calculus of what it would
take to have a permanent station say on
the moon or on Mars
it's a great question and looking into
the far future the first thing that I
think about is actually radiation
protection and keeping our humans uh
very healthy and well alive and so if
this isn't messing with our genome yet
if there are radiation hard folks folks
who are resistant to the harms of
radiation let's send them just naturally
you're saying naturally naturally yeah
hypotheses out there we might some
people might already have this
protection so that's incredible science
and of course the evidence of that I
mean there is there's some hypotheses
and why is that so important well it's
important for for cancer here on Earth
that's why I'm so excited about it you
can find those genetics find folks that
are not predisposed to radiation damage
that would be huge so if the science
unfolds and we have that that evidence
then absolutely that those would make
the best candidates because it's all
about again round trip bringing people
back alive and and well and then we'll
learn as we go uh in terms of you know
protection and sending folks who've
asked about also the let's give people
the the best the best chance that they
they can absolutely so in terms of
nutrition in terms of all of the
physiology that I say the muscles the
bones keeping them you know really at
top performance is how you know I think
that that again the science and
experiments will unfold to keep people
um you know in great shape well in life
and we learn about aging we learn about
so much uh in terms of the pathology
here on Earth so that's really the
benefit is thinking about the Earth
applications if we're really pushing not
just our Technologies but our scientific
understanding for deep space exploration
and Thomas just jumping off from that
you mentioned earlier I think both of
you did that we want to have a
partnership between a live human being
and robots is that's perhaps the most
powerful way that we can go forward now
and of course it makes a lot of sense
with the state of Robotics now where
there's clearly a difference in judgment
and and certain kind of cognitive
capacities that that a living system has
compared to a robot that's going to
change you know with AI and deep
learning so so can you imagine a Time
perhaps even In Our Lifetime where it
really will be sending out the
artificial life system and they're able
to do just as good as we if not better
when it comes to issues like judgment
so I always think about the progress
we've made in Ai and then I look at the
spell checker and the iPhone and I'm
deeply disappointed like you know it's
trying to guess my words and it comes up
with words I have no idea what they mean
so kind of my point is there's still
ways to go I do believe for making a lot
of progress right even just if you look
in our lifetimes how our little
companions in our pockets how they have
kind of affected how we're going like no
we're not driving up to the restaurant
to figure out whether there's space
there we kind of like we have
information that comes to us uh on Mars
right kind of one of the things I'm so
excited about is uh you know we have an
astronaut standing on the surface of
Mars right sure there will be
accompanied by a flying robot that will
help them figure out which direction to
go roam and find the most relevant rocks
and I really do believe that development
kind of again with individual robot but
also just that connection how using
information is going to dramatically
shift and change as we go forward even
here on Earth 10 years from now we'll be
in in a different place than we are
today just look where we've come from in
the last 10.
yeah without a doubt
um let me ask you both one final
question start with you Thomas so I
started this conversation I don't know
if you're within earshot when I began
knowing that like many kids when I was a
kid I dreamed of being an astronaut and
quickly realized that I was not one of
those endowed with intrinsic physiology
that was well suited to that kind of an
undertaking you know claustrophobia and
sea sickness and so forth so I will
never go to space sadly
um if there is an opportunity Thomas for
you to go to space
um would you take it is that something
that you would want to do
you know it's interesting if you ask me
that question five years ago I would
have said no and I did say no in many
interviews and the answer today is yes
absolutely and and frankly I became an
astrophysicist because of the night sky
it always attracted me I thought it was
amazing that we could build robots uh
but I'm I'm compelled by the progress
we've made and I'm really excited about
the opportunities that are provided to
us by uh you know crude uh you know
exploration together with robotics so if
there's an opportunity surely I will go
and uh David I'm going to give you the
last word are you going to take that
prototype spacesuit and uh put it to
real work out there in space I would I
would love to I would go in a second I
am going to come back home and and more
importantly for me now as my students
that are the new Artemis uh astronauts
and will be the first astronauts to go
to to Mars so kind of paying it forward
so it's going to be I think hopefully
you know one of our one of our our
students or someone someone listening to
this they're going to be the the first
folks to you know have boot prints on uh
on Mars and as our colleagues and
friends and students who are already in
the the Artemis crew so that's uh that's
that's it's just an incredible future
there's gonna be a lot more people in
space there's going to be I think I'm
putting a lot more in law with orbit
it'll be fantastic we'll be working and
Manufacturing and doing a lot there and
so a lot more people are going to have
the opportunity to fly to fly in space
and uh that's a that's a future I want
to live in yeah it's wonderfully
exciting and so congratulations to you
both for all the work you've done to
make what we're now seeing come true and
all the work that you've done setting us
up for the next stage as we go forward
to the moon and Beyond to Mars and uh
and best of luck going forward and
thanks for spending the time with us
today
thank you so much go Artemis thank you
goodness
and for everybody else who's been
watching this program please know that
world Science Festival is coming out
with a whole variety of interesting
programming if you've missed any of our
previous episodes you can see them at
our website world sciencefestival.com or
on YouTube programs and psychedelics and
on the nature of dreaming are two recent
ones that I think were quite wonderful
so if you haven't seen those they're
they're definitely worth your attention
and going forward we have some wonderful
programs on the ancient history of our
and related species as well as a look at
the human brain cosmology quantum
entanglement Quantum Computing deep
learning artificial intelligence so you
should definitely sign up to the world
Science Festival YouTube channel and to
our newsletter to be kept apprised of
these programs as we release them
great so thank you for joining us and I
look forward to seeing you at our next
live session from New York this is Brian
Green
[Music]
foreign
[Music]